we know that any sexually reproducing
organism is getting dna from both its
male parent and its female parent
and that's true also for human beings
you might know we have 23 pairs of
chromosomes but let's zoom in on one of
those pairs so let's say this is one of
the chromosomes in a pair and let's say
that this is the other chromosome in the
pair so one came from one parent the
other came from the other parent
chromosomes are nothing more than
bunched up strands of dna plus other
things that help package it so let's
unravel a little bit to understand how
these relate to genes and then we'll
dive into a little bit more terminology
around genetics
so you have this big long strand of dna
and segments of this code for different
genes maybe this part right over here is
related to how tall you become
so let's say that part right over there
that might be related to hair color and
in other videos we talk about how these
genes can essentially be translated
eventually into proteins which are
expressed in forms like height or hair
color or eye color or
many many many many other ways
but each of these chromosomes actually
code generally speaking for the same
genes so if this one has a region that
codes for that gene this one will as
well
and this one
will also the other chromosome in the
pair will also have a region that codes
for this other gene
now as you can imagine
the genes that get translated into
proteins that eventually are show up in
your hair color they can come in
different versions
so what we call the different versions
of a gene is
an allele
so for example
from
this parent you might have gotten the
allele here that would describe let's
say
blonde hair
i'll denote that with lowercase b
while from this parent you might have
gotten the allele that's associated with
say brown hair
so they're both associated or they're
both coding for the same type of protein
that might play a role in hair color but
they're different versions of it so you
could view an allele as
versions
or
a version i'll say alleles are versions
of
a gene
now if you know which versions you have
then you're able to say i know my or i
know the organism's genotype so in this
situation we know we have the capital b
allele which is for the brown hair and
we have the lowercase b allele which is
for the blonde hair and so the genotype
in this situation where you actually
know
what alleles you have you would say that
that is
you have a capital b from one parent and
you have the lowercase b
from another parent now the thing you
might be asking is but what does this
organism look like how does this
genotype actually get expressed and if
you're asking that question you're
asking a question of phenotype
phenotype is what is expressed
and this is usually observable in some
way so the phenotype in this situation
might be and it's seldom this simple in
genetics but we're going to make it
simple in in this scenario that if you
have a brown allele and a blond allele
then maybe the brown allele is dominant
which is that if you have even one brown
allele at the end of the day you're
going to see brown so i'll just write
that down for this scenario although
that's not actually going to be the case
genetics gets a lot more complicated
than that but certain genes certain
alleles they do they are that simply
dominant or recessive
now you can imagine there's many
different genotypes based on what i just
described that could result in this
phenotype
you could have
this genotype that we just showed you
could get a brown allele from both
parents
either of these genotypes would express
themselves as the phenotype brown
if we assume and that is a big if if we
assume that this is the dominant version
of the gene or the dominant allele if
that is then in either case it will
express itself as the phenotype of brown
the only way you would get blonde hair
in this scenario is if you had two of
the recessive gene or the recessive
version of the gene or the recessive
allele this would lead to
blonde a blonde phenotype right over
here we've talked about dominant alleles
we've talked about recessive alleles
and another piece of terminology that
you will hear when you talk about
genetics are notions of homozygous
homozygous
and or versus
heterozygous
genotypes and when people are talking
about homozygous or heterozygous they're
talking about the genotype homozygous
you might know the prefix homo refers to
same so this is a situation where both
the alleles are the same same
alleles
and heterozygous is a situation where
hetero that's referring to different
different
alleles
so what would we call this scenario
right over here we would call this a
heterozygous genotype for this gene
this would be homozygous dominant we
have two of the same dominant allele and
this would be homozygous recessive
i'll leave you there you're now armed to
talk a lot about genetics